Bitte schön.
Guten Tag. Ich heiße Dr. Korkmaz. Ich bin der Disaventure Arzt auf dieser Station.
Ich wollte nur fragen. Korkmaz, haben Sie gesagt?
Ja, Korkmaz, mein Nachname.
Wie schreibt sich Ihr Name? Ich möchte mitschreiben.
Ahmet Korkmaz.
Wie schreibt sich Ihr Name, Dr. Korkmaz?
Ah.
Den Nachnamen brauche ich.
Ja.
SZ.
Danke, Doktor Konkmaß. Entschuldigung, dass ich die gefragt habe, weil ich möchte gerne immer Notizen machen von den Ärzten, die mich betreuen.
Ja, natürlich. Ja, natürlich. Ja, natürlich.
Doktor, ich bitte um Entschuldigung. Ich habe ein bisschen Luft, deswegen kann ich manchmal nicht so direkt antworten.
Ja, okay. Darf ich Ihren Namen lernen?
Ja, mein Name ist Thomas Mann.
Nachname ist Mann.
Okay, Herr Mann. Seit wann haben Sie Atomnot?
Doktor, seit ungefähr drei Stunden hat angefangen mit einem starken Schmerz auf der rechten Seite hier oben.
Seitdem habe ich Luftnot, sobald ich mich ein bisschen bewege, wird es schon schwierig.
Ich husste ab und zu und ich merke auch, dass es so ein bisschen mal Puls raast.
Okay Herr Mann, ich werde unsere Gespräche unterbrechen und ich kontrolliere ihre
Vitalparameter und eine EKF-Verschreibung. Okay?
Okay, gut. Alles klar, Doktor, machen wir. Also die Vitalparameter sind,
die Sättigung ist 95 Prozent, der Druck ist 150 zu 85 und die Frequenz 120 pro Minute.
Ein schönes Spiel kanns? 120 pro Minute. EKG zeigt Sinus Tarekati, sonst keine
Auffälligkeiten. Okay, okay Herr Mann, ich habe...
Der Doktor hat mir jetzt eine Sauerstoffe gegeben. Ja natürlich.
Es geht jetzt ein bisschen besser jetzt. 95 Prozent, 95 Prozent, okay.
Herr Mann, Sie haben eine, ja Sie haben Herzrasen und seit wann haben Sie auch,
seit drei Stunden auch? Ja, so ungefähr vor drei Stunden ist plötzlich angefangen.
Vorher war gar nichts gewesen, Doktor. Okay, haben Sie bemerkt etwas als Auslöser?
Doktor, ich muss sagen, ich kann es Ihnen nicht sagen. Ich weiß, es kam aus alter
dem Himmel. Okay Herr Mann, ich möchte ein paar
Ihre persönlichen Daten aufnehmen. Ja, wie alt sind Sie? Ich werde dieses Jahr 33.
33, okay. Und wie viel wiegeln Sie? Wie viel ich wiege? Ja, ungefähr so 68 Kilo.
68, okay. Und wie groß sind Sie? 1,85 Meter. Okay, lastes, wann sind Sie genau gebogen?
Am 9. September 1990. 99, 90, ja. 1990, ja. Okay, okay Herr Mann,
haben Sie früher ähnliche Beschwerden? Nein, Doktor, das ist das erste Mal. Ich möchte ein
kurzer Zusammenfassung. Sie haben seit drei Stunden rechseitige Schmerzen,
in Brust oder Bauch? Brust, Brust, Brust-Schmerzen, okay. Und auch Atemnobprobleme? Ja.
Und manchmal Hüsten? Ja, Hüsten habe ich auch mehr. Okay, und Sie haben nicht damit eine Auflöser?
Nein, habe ich keinen Auslöser bemerkt.
Okay.
Richtig.
Herr Mann, haben Sie in letzter Zeit einer langen Reise gemacht?
Vor etwa sechs Wochen hatte ich Urlaub, weil ich verreist nach Dubai.
Dubai?
Ja.
Okay, wie viele Stunden haben Sie geflogen?
Da dauert es ungefähr fünf, sechs Stunden.
Okay.
Herr Mann, sollen Sie sich fieberig?
Nein, Doktor, ich habe keinen Fieber.
Ich habe auch gemessen.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen öbel?
Kann ich so nicht sagen, nein.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Also, wenn ich Luftnot habe und mich bewege, dann ist mir ein bisschen...
Schwindelig ist so viel, aber ich fühle mich nicht so richtig wie früher.
Okay.
Leichte, man kann sagen, oder?
Vielleicht kann man sagen, leichte Schwindel.
Leichte.
Ich möchte über Ihre Schmerzen ein paar Fragen stellen.
Sind die Schmerzen irgendwo ausstrahlen?
Das ist eine ganze Brustkorb auf der rechten Seite.
Und wenn ich tief atme, muss ich dann husten, wird dann noch schlimmer.
Bei husten wird schlimmer.
Wenn ich tief versuche zu atmen, dann wird es schlimmer.
Und gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt aus Rüsten?
Also, ich habe wegen der Schmerzen zu Hause noch so Novalgientropfen gehabt.
Die habe ich genommen, aber die haben nicht so viel gebracht.
Nicht mehr geholfen?
Nein, nicht so viel.
Kaum.
Okay.
Okay, Herr Mann.
Jetzt möchte ich ein paar über Ihre generelle Zustandsfragen stellen.
Haben Sie Probleme, Stuhlgang oder Wasserlassen in letzter Zeit?
Also in letzter Zeit nicht, aber ich hatte früher mal Probleme mit Stuhlgang.
Ich hatte Morbus Crohn.
Aber da habe ich die Krankheit vor fünf Jahren Diagnose gestellt worden.
Aber ich bin seit drei Jahren keine Probleme und nehme auch keine Medikamente einzurteilt.
Momentan haben Sie keine Medikamente eingerohnt?
Im August Grund nehme ich keine Medikamente ein.
Okay.
Stuhlgang ist normal jetzt aktuell?
Normal.
Sind Sie schlafen Sie ausreichend?
Ich habe Schlafprobleme.
Deswegen nehme ich manchmal auch Medikamente zum Einschlafen.
Um Einschlafen?
Ja.
Was nehmen Sie?
Zopiklon.
Könnten Sie, wie das wurde?
Zopiklon, mit Z-C-O-P-I-C-L-O-N.
Okay.
Wie viele Kisten brauchen Sie umschlafen?
Eins.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme außer Morbus Crohn als Vorerkrankungen?
Ja.
Ich hatte mal einen Unfall.
Ein Fahrradunfall.
Das war auch so ungefähr vor zehn Jahren.
Da war ich noch ein Stück alt.
Dann habe ich eine Milzruptur.
Milzruptur?
Ja.
Okay.
Es war ein Fahrradunfall.
Und die Operation war problemlos, oder?
Das war als Notfall.
Ja, meine Meinung ist, haben Sie keine Probleme bei,
hatten Sie keine Probleme bei Operation?
Nach der Operation keine.
Ja, okay.
Ich habe noch Gastritis.
Ich habe eine Endoskopie bekommen.
Als diese Morbus Crohn-Erkrankung festgestellt wurde,
habe ich Gastritis gehabt.
Nehmen Sie dagegen irgendwelche Medikamente?
Ich habe nicht Pantoprazol ein, aber nicht regelmäßig.
Okay, bei Bedarf.
Ja.
Und es ist damals noch festgestellt worden,
dass ich eine Hypercholesterinämie habe,
eine Cholesterineröhung.
Okay, ich habe eine Medikamente aufgeschrieben bekommen,
aber ich nehme das nicht mehr ein.
Okay.
Okay, noch etwas?
Das sind so die wichtigsten Krankheiten.
Okay, Herr Mann.
Sind Sie vollständig gegen Corona?
Ja, gegen Corona auch.
Und dann habe ich auch wegen der Milzoperation
noch andere Impfungen bekommen,
noch gegen Plomococcus.
Ja, super.
Das ist komplett mein Impfschutz.
Ja, das ist sehr gut.
Ist Ihnen irgendwelche Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Nein, nichts bekannt.
Okay.
Herr Mann, rauchen Sie?
Ja, leider.
Wie viel ist Zigarette und seit wann?
Also, ich rauche seit ungefähr 14, 15 Jahren alt bin.
Und ja, das ist mal mehr, mal weniger.
Manchmal sind auch zwei Schachten Zigaretten pro Tag.
Manchmal.
Okay. Man kann sagen, ein oder 15 Zigarette durchschnittlich?
Ja, so ein bis zwei Päckchen pro Tag, ja.
Manchmal sogar, also überwiegend zwei sogar,
seit letzten Jahren, ja.
Okay. Es ist so, ja, viel.
Ich kann Ihnen nach der Behandlung
unsere soziale Beratung und aufhören, aufzuhören.
Also da, der Doktor ist, ich werde es mir vornehmen, ja.
Okay. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Eigentlich nur am Wochenende, sonst in der Woche nicht.
Okay.
Und nehmen Sie nächste Frage nicht persönlich.
Nehmen Sie eine Routinefrage?
Haben Sie Erfahrungen mit Drogen?
Ja, als Student habe ich Drogen konsumiert, ja.
Was trinken oder rauchen?
Also, wir haben ein bisschen Mario Hanna genutzt.
Und ich habe auch so extra Sie genommen.
Aber jetzt, also seitdem ich arbeite, ist das komplett weg.
Okay, das ist er.
Okay, Herr Mann, wir sind fast fertig.
Ich möchte ein paar Fragen über Ihre Familie,
Familienzustand und Familie Schicht stellen.
Ja.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, Sie leben beide noch, ja.
Leiden Sie an irgendwelche Krankungen?
Ja, also meine Mutter hat Diabetes.
Und hat auch Bluthochdruck und hat auch mein Herzinfarkt gehabt.
Okay.
Und mein Vater hat der Lungenprobleme, also COPD und MfV-Sem.
COPD und?
MfV-Sem hat er.
MfV-Sem, okay.
Haben Sie Ihre Schwester?
Ja, ich habe noch zwei weitere Geschwister.
Also eine Schwester hat auch Morbus Crohn wie ich.
Und der andere Bruder hat jetzt keine Schwere der Krankung.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihre Familie stand?
Ich bin feiereratet.
Ich habe zwei Kinder.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Softwareentwickler.
In IT-Bereich?
Ja, in IT-Bereich.
Ich habe so ein bisschen Druck manchmal,
die Projekte zu Ende kommen,
es ist ein bisschen stressig,
aber was soll man machen?
Ist jeder Brubes stressig für sich?
Ja.
Ist es ein bisschen regelmäßig Sport-Tragung?
Kaum, da komme ich nicht dazu.
Okay.
Ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie irgendwelche Fragen oder hinzufindeln?
Doktor, ich habe Angst,
dass ich vom Herzen Probleme bekomme.
Meine Mutter hatte ja auch Herzinfarkt.
Ich habe auch, falls das eine schlimme Krankheit sein sollte,
ich habe eine Patientenverfügung.
Ich möchte keine lebensverlängernden Maßnahmen haben.
Ich möchte nicht an die Maschine gängig werden.
Kann man das so planen,
wenn etwas Schlimmes rauskommen sollte?
Herr Mann, momentan,
wir haben nur unsere Aufnahmegesprache durchgeführt.
Ich muss eigentlich Körperlöse untersuchen,
dünne, danach ein paar Bildgewände verfahren,
um ihre Situation abzuklären.
Aber natürlich habe ich eine Verdachtdiagnose.
Ich vermute,
dass Sie nicht über Ihre Herz, sondern über Ihre Lunge haben.
Ich vermute, dass Sie eine Trombose haben,
vielleicht wegen Ihrer langen Reise,
Ihrer langen Reise,
gesagt.
Ich habe schon gesagt,
ich werde Ihre Körperlöse untersuchen dürfen,
danach nehme ich Blut ab,
ich kontrolliere manche Parameter,
besonders über Trombolib.
Und danach sprechen wir.
Aber ich wollte nur sichergehen,
dass, wenn etwas passieren sollte,
ich da nicht an die Maschine gängig werde.
Machen Sie keine Sorge,
Sie sind momentan gute Hände,
Sie kommen gleichzeitig hier.
Ich kümmere Sie um Sie.
Soll ich Ihnen noch mal meine Patientenaufklärung geben?
Da steht drin,
dass ich keine fünzliche Ernährung haben möchte,
dass ich keine Maschinenbeatmung haben möchte.
Wollen Sie das noch mal haben?
Natürlich, wir kontrollieren Sie so.
Ich meine, falls es nachts etwas sein sollte,
wenn der Dienstarzt mich nicht kennt,
und etwas passiert,
dann hilft es ihm, eine Entscheidung zu treffen.
Natürlich, ich spreche mit meiner Oberarzt.
Dann gibt es eine Patienteverfügung,
damit Sie das in meinen Akte tun,
dass ich keine lebensverlängerenden Maßnahmen haben möchte.
Ich nehme Sie auf die stationäre Behandlung.
Aber momentan machen Sie keine Luftmaschine,
nur in unserer stationären Behandlung.
Was meinen Sie?
Intensivstation, vielleicht,
aber ich muss meine Oberarzt sprechen.
Intensivstation, ich möchte nicht an die Maschine.
Sie brauchen keine Maschine,
Ihre Stoffsäure, Städtebuch ist sehr gut.
Aber wir müssen darauf achten.
Was sagen Sie, diese Trombose,
die ich habe in der Lunge, haben Sie gesagt?
Vielleicht, das ist nur eine Verdachtdiagnose.
Alles klar, Dr. Vielen Dank für die gute Betreuung.
Okay, danke.
Gibt es Fragen, die Sie noch gestellt hätten?
Ich habe noch ein paar Fragen,
wenn aus dem Chatnix kommt.
Was kommt?
Haben Sie eine Schwellung oder schmeißt Sie den Bein bemerkt?
Wenn Sie Verdacht haben, Trompe im Bolize,
das ist eine gute Frage, hat keine Schwellung der Beine bemerkt?
Mit Auswurf bemerkt?
Auswurf?
Auswurf.
Hat keinen Auswurf.
Trocken aus dem Schwellen.
Das wird sich entstanden.
Können Sie die Schmerzen bemerken?
Stechende Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1-10,
ungefähr 9.
9.
Herr Kollege,
erst mal müssen wir eine Welche reagieren zeigen.
Zum Beispiel,
schließe Sie am Unteran
und körperliche Untersuchung sofort.
Zum Beispiel höre ich ab.
Kann man machen, ja.
Wichtig war, diese Vitalparameter war okay.
Es ist nicht kritisch der Patient,
kein Schockindex oder so.
Aber so etwas kann im Laufe des Gesprächs noch schlimmer werden.
Aber 1 oder 2 Minuten,
dann eine Schock, ich denke.
Anpassieren, ja.
Patriation ist 95,
Puls 120,
33 Jahre Patrient.
1 oder 2 Minuten,
Maximum, Immigrät, Schock.
Aber dafür ist es im Krankenhaus,
dann kann er reanimiert werden,
auch wenn er nicht lebenslängende Maßnahmen haben möchte.
Ja, reagiert.
Also ich hätte jetzt auch den Patienten,
erst mal EKG war richtig,
also Ausstoß von einer Kardianischämie,
das krieg ich gut.
Aber ich hätte den Patienten dann,
wenn ich schon mal so ein bisschen Diagnostik gemacht habe,
erst mal Auskutation vielleicht gemacht.
Auskutation, ja.
Spontampinamaturak Sabah.
Das ist die Diagnose, ja.
Ein Meter, ein Meter fünf und 80,
ein bisschen beschwerden,
wir haben nicht gefragt.
Er hat gefragt, er hatte früher aber nie gefragt.
Familie, Familie,
müssen wir fragen.
Familie ist gefragt worden,
der Vater hatte COPD und M4C.
Ja, M4C.
Also kann natürlich eine familiäre Belastung sein.
Ja, aber er hat auch Zigarettenrauchen,
also er kann nicht auch Infusäme haben.
Und spontan ruptur von Infusämenblasen
kann man spontan Pneumotorax machen.
Jetzt sind wir schon bei den Komplikationen,
die sie fragen, was kann passieren in so einem Gespräch,
bei spontan Pneumotorax.
Also, Entschuldigung, hier ist der große Problem,
dass sie nicht operiert werden.
Oder sie müssen nicht,
die künstliche Intellation oder Maschine.
Das ist ein Thema, das sprechen wir noch mal später, ja.
Aber was kann passieren?
Es kann einen Spannungspneumotorax geben,
Spannungspneumotorax.
Das ist dann ein Notfall, wo sie reagieren.
Das ist lebendbedrohtliche Situation.
Also, wenn ich so einen Patienten hätte,
hätte ich genauso gemacht,
aber ich hätte noch mal kurz Auskutation gemacht.
Und wenn ich da unsicher wäre,
hätte ich den direkt mal zum Röntgen geschickt, glaube ich.
Aber man kann bei einem stabilen Patienten auch mal,
das so ein bisschen nach dem Gespräch auch aufschieben,
dieses Röntgen.
Also, könnte man machen.
Das ist jetzt kein Fehler.
Okay, was gibt es noch für Sachen,
die sie fragen wollten?
Im Chat habe ich gelesen, Fieber hat der Kollege gefragt,
kein Fieber, hat ich schon gefragt worden,
ist er bei Belastung ein Ruhe aufgetreten?
Das war aus heiterem Himmel, sagt er,
aus Ruhe heraus.
Und für das der Knobsponentant Pneumotox, ja, das stimmt.
Hier ist nicht nötig, aber vielleicht kann man auch fragen,
irgendwie ist Ihre Gewicht in der Läste-Seite ab
oder zugenommen, hat sich verändert.
Man kann fragen können, aber es ist sowieso schon schlank.
Also, klar, wenn er jetzt vorher 90 kg gewogen hat,
ist das schon wichtig.
Er hat nicht abgenommen, er ist stabil, immer schlank.
Das ist auch so typisch bei diesen Patienten,
die Pneumotox bekommen,
die sind eher so astänisch, dünne Patienten.
Also, nicht immer, aber meistens so.
Traum hat er gefragt, also er hat nicht gefragt,
er hat gestürzt, aber er hat gefragt,
gab es einen Auslöser, ja?
Ja.
Deswegen, es gab keinen Auslöser.
Man kann aber nochmal gezielt fragen,
fragen oder nur Auslöser fragen.
Traum war besser, weil für Patienten das Auslöser kann alles sein.
Kann Glaswein sein, kann keine Ahnung,
Computerspiel sein, Aufregung, ja,
ich meine, das ist ein alles Auslöser.
Traum wäre noch genauer, ja, wenn man sagt,
hatten Sie eine Verletzung oder einen Unfall gehabt
in den letzten Tagen oder so, ja.
Aber Auslöser ist auch schon okay.
Man kann mal durchgehen lassen, ja.
Das ist kein Fehler.
Als Herr Schiffler anfangen, Jan.
Okay, dann haben wir Arztgespräch, ja.
Hallo, mein Oberarzt, ich habe eine neue Patient.
Ich möchte Ihnen vorstellen,
haben Sie dafür Kurse bereit?
Ja, bitte, gerne.
Thomas Mann, 33-jährige Patient,
er kann heute,
wegen Zeitdreifthunde,
5.Jh., Brustschimmersen,
Brustschimmersen, Toraximmersen,
Rex-Zeitig-Toraximmersen,
die Schimmersen sind bei 9,
bei 8 bis 9 auf einer Skala
und sie sind steckend.
Der Patient klagte auch über
düstere Kusten seit 3 Stunden.
Bei Kusten, die Schimmersen,
sind die Schimmersen schlimmer geworden.
Ich habe bei Aufnahmegesprache,
die Vitalparameter und EKG kontrolliert.
Stoff-Sor-Sättigung 35%.
35?
Entschuldigung, 95.
Okay, dann ist gut.
95.
120.
140.
180.
Die EKG ist unauffällig,
bis
6 Wochen eine Rangereis gemacht.
Die EKG ist unabhängig,
aber die EKG ist unabhängig,
und die EKG ist unabhängig,
die EKG ist unabhängig.
Vor 6 Wochen eine Rangereis gemacht,
aber ich vermute,
dass momentan nicht
Entschuldigung, ich weiter mache.
Er leidet seit fünf Jahren Morbus Kuron, aber ist gut eingestellt.
Seit ungefähr drei Jahren hat er keine Medikamente dagegen
eingenommen.
Vor zehn Jahren hatte er einen Fahrradunfall.
Er hatte Missruppungen und wurde operiert.
Er klagte auch über Gastritis und nimmt bei Bedarf Pantoprosol.
Er ist vollständig geübt.
Er hat keine Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten.
Er ruft seit ungefähr 17 Jahren ein bis zwei Pektionssigaretten.
Sie trinkt eleganten Alkohol und bei Studium hat er Mariano und manchmal
Extasi genutzt.
Er ist verheiratet, hat zwei gesunde Kinder.
Er arbeitet bei IT Bereich, macht kaum Sport.
Seine Vater leidet an SOPD und Mfizan.
Seine Mutter leidet an Diabetes Melutus, Arteriola Hepatoni.
Sie hat einmal Akupmiacardinfarktus gehabt und mit Standsbehandelungen.
Er hat zwei Geschwister, ein Schwester, ein Bruder und ihre Schwester hat auch Morbus Kuron.
Haben Sie den Patienten abgehört?
Noch nicht.
Haben wir den Patienten mal abgemeinert?
Was hören wir?
Ich werde körperliche Untersuchungen und ich höre auf seine Blumen.
Ich mache natürlich eine Herz- und Partizie.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtsignose, bevor wir weitergehen?
Was ist Ihre Verdachtsignose?
Meine Verdachtsignose ist spontan.
Als differenzialen Diagnose kommen die Pulmener und die Trombo-Emboli.
Und die Lungen-Emboli und die KHK.
Was ist die KHK?
Corona-Herz-Krankheit.
Macht Corona-Herz-Krankheit Schmerzen?
Eigentlich nicht mehr, aber ich muss kontrollieren.
Was macht denn Schmerzen?
Ich weiß, was Sie meinen, aber die KHK ist nicht die Verdachtsdiagnose beim Patienten.
Wenn eine KHK auf dem Boden hätte, hat die Diagnose einen Was gehabt?
Ja, ja.
Bei der KHK?
Ja, ja, ja.
Akut Kauaner-Sendronen.
Ja, genau.
Alles klar.
Jetzt ist unsere Verdachtsdiagnose schon gesagt.
Spontanpnomotox, Sie hören den Patienten ab.
Was erwarten, oder Sie untersuchen ihn die Lunge?
Keine Lungengeräusche, die betreffen Seite.
Wenn er Lungengeräusche hat, ist das dann ausgeschlossen?
Und natürlich Torax Röntgen.
Er ist erst mal bei der körperlichen Untersuchung.
Sie untersuchen ihn, hören die Lunge ab, hier, hören Sie Atemgeräusche.
Das meinen Sie ja.
Ist dann der Torax vom Tisch?
Was ist damit die Diagnose?
Ist der Torax nicht mehr möglich?
Ja, ich werde ihn nämlich nicht momentan.
Was sind denn so die typischen Befunde?
Sie haben gesagt, also aufgehobenes Atemgeräusch, ja, das kann sein.
Wie ist das Atemgeräusch normal?
Wie nennt man das?
Aktagesunden Seite.
Wesikuläres Atemgeräusch.
Wenn Pnomotorx ist, kann entweder sein aufgehobenes Atemgeräusch
oder, was ist häufiger, weil es ja meistens kein komplettes Atelaktase der Lunge ist.
Das Sie noch hören, aber das ist anders als hier.
Hier ist normal und hier ist wie Atemgeräusch.
Perchobung.
Sag man nicht.
Perchison bei der Perchison.
Wir sind jetzt bei Auskitation erst mal.
Also hier links ist normal, es wird Atemgeräusch
und rechts ist Pnomotorx.
Keine.
Entweder, keine oder, Sie hören was?
Abgeschwächtes Atemgeräusch, ja.
Abgeschwächtes, also es ist hier und Seitenunterschied.
Hier ist normal, hier ist ein bisschen leiser.
Das ist eher, ja, das ist normal.
Abgeschwächtes Atemgeräusch, ja.
Oder, was auch sein kann, Sie hören hier und hier,
ist alles normal, bald ist es gleich.
Gleich hat es Geräusch.
Wo hört man dann noch gerne?
Die Basallungern-Basell.
Die Basall hier unten?
Ja.
Ist so?
Weil wo ist Pnomotorx am häufigsten ausgeprägt,
wenn die Lunge kollabiert, am häufigsten?
Ich meine nicht.
Der Lungenabex kollabiert meistens, ja.
Also das ist hier oben dann frei.
Deswegen müssen Sie Auskutation hier in der Superklavicular-Grube,
Städoskop hier hinalben, da und da.
Wenn Sie hier etwas hören und hier nicht,
dann haben Sie auch den Verdacht auf Pnomotorx, ja.
Superklavicular-Region hier oben.
Bei Patienten empfüßend, die haben ja sowieso hier,
so Lunge ist ja noch weiter nach oben gekommen.
Und dann können Sie hier abhören.
Und dann, wenn Sie da Unterschied merken,
oder es ist oft nicht vorhanden,
dann ist es auch ein Hinweis für Pnomotorx, ja.
Weil manchmal hört man, das klingt überall gleich.
Deswegen immer hier oben auch hören, ja.
Weil da ist die häufigste Stelle,
die sich ablöst von der Plurra, ja.
So wie der Plurrasch bald dann groß wird.
Jetzt haben wir Auskutation gemacht
und jetzt haben wir noch Perkussion,
wollen wir noch machen.
Wie ist bei Pnomotorx der Perkussions befunden?
Ist der normal, wenn Sie klopfen?
Wie nennt man das?
Nicht Sonne.
Sonne.
Ja, Sonne.
Und wenn es dann, wie ist bei Pnomotorx?
Wie heißt das?
Perkussion.
Das bedeutet klöpfschal.
Klöpfschal.
Was?
Wenn Sie den Befehl befunden schreiben,
dann schreiben Sie Pulmodoppelpunkt.
Auskutation, oder Sie schreiben hin.
Vessikuläres Atemgeräusch, links,
rechts.
Abbeschwertes Atemgeräusch.
Dann Klöpfschalpdoppelpunkt,
links Sonneur,
rechts, hypersonore,
Klöpfschalpdoppelpunkt.
Das wäre so der typische
körperliche Untersuchungsbefund
bei Pnomotorx, ja.
Gut, und dann haben Sie es festgestellt,
festgestellt, was machen Sie als nächstes?
Röntgen, Torax.
Okay.
Röntgen kann man das dann sehen.
Ja.
Und wenn Sie jetzt, okay, also nehmen Sie auch Blutabereinpatienten, machen Sie immer, oder?
Blut, EKG und Blut wird immer gemacht, glaube ich.
Ja.
Und nachgucken Sie, bei der Differenzialdiagnose haben Sie schon gesagt, ACS.
Bei Blutuntersuchung, große Blutbild, Entzündeparameter, Herzparameter,
Proponin und der KJKNB und der DEMA und Blutgasanalys.
Richtig, ja.
Und Blutgasanalys.
Das reicht mir schon, das sind die wichtigsten Notfallmaßnahmen Labor.
Ja.
Gut.
Was machen Sie?
Jetzt haben Sie Röntgen gesehen, so ein Motorks.
Was machen Sie mit den Patienten?
Die intensive Stationen.
Ja.
Die haben kein Bett.
Die haben voll, was machen Sie?
Nein.
Bis sie 3 Stunden, 6 Stunden auf Bett warten, müssen Sie was machen?
Nein, ich weiß nicht.
Wollen Sie auf dem Motorks?
Er ist erst mal groß ab einem Motorks.
Was machen Sie?
Warten Sie, bis die Station frei ist?
Bett oder nicht?
Ja, ich denke, ich muss, ja, sagen, irgendwo in Krankenhaus eine.
Sie sind ja im Krankenhaus, Sie sind bei der Notaufnahme.
Aber, ja.
Sie sind Notfallarzt.
Sie können das.
Das können Sie machen.
Und eine Typ drinnen.
Sie legen einen Torx-Train.
Wo legt man die Typikerweise?
Im OP, klar.
Manchmal kann man auch in der Ambulanz legen.
Wo legen Sie die Torx-Train oben, unten, vorne?
Ja, unten, weil die Luft geht.
Wo legt man die Torx-Train?
Ja, ich höre von der Doktor.
Die Interkostal ist klar, aber wo?
Sie wissen, sie sind 6 und 7.
Wir haben in Deutschland immer 2. ICR,
Medioklavikularlinie.
Normalerweise.
Aber das kann man natürlich auch abhängig machen,
wo der Pnomotorhalsbrunnenbild am meisten ist.
Man kann auch weiter unten gehen.
Normalerweise ist es immer 2. ICR,
2. Medioklavikularlinie.
Da legt man die Torx-Train.
Aber es müssen Sie entscheiden.
Sie machen auch die Torx-Train.
Normalerweise Röntgen.
Dann macht man auch auf Ultraschall.
Schaut, ob die Flüssigkeit ist.
Dann legt man die Drainage.
Unter lokaler Betäubung.
Dann machen Sie etwas dran.
Einfach nur Drainagen.
Dann abstöpsten.
Was machen Sie mit der Drainage?
Sie haben ein Schlauch gelegt.
Wo kommt der Schlauch hin?
Ist er zu?
Ich habe es nicht.
Wo kommt der Schlauch hin?
Ist er zu?
Es ist unterschiedlich.
Im Lehrbuch ist es mehr Medioklaviklarlinie.
Ich habe kein Problem, wenn man es seitlich macht.
Aber meistens oben.
2. bis 4. ICR würde ich sagen.
Wir haben auch mal Patienten, wo wir unten legen.
Wenn oben die Lunge fixiert ist.
Da gibt es einen Basalenpnomotorhalsbrunnenbild.
Manchmal gibt es auch.
Da kann man auch die Lunge fixieren.
Man kann es dann entscheiden.
Normalerweise ist Lehrbuch, wir wissen immer, 2. ICR.
Medioklaviklarlinie.
Da ist die Komplikationsrate am geringsten vermutlich.
Okay.
Oder hintere Axilaline.
Das haben Sie auch aufgemacht.
Ja, meistens.
Wir haben meistens bis 7.
Im Teilkursant Axilaline.
Okay.
Ich bin kein Torx-Chirurg.
Deswegen will ich mich nicht zu sehr äußern.
Aber wir haben es so gelernst.
Aber da will ich mich nicht festlegen.
Aber was machen Sie mit der Drainage?
Machen Sie einfach dann Drainage, schlafen Sie dann an die Luft hängen?
Oder wie machen Sie das?
Ich habe noch nicht die Rucke von Sölder.
Momentan, ich bin nicht.
Wir müssen entweder einen Sorgkern machen,
oder Sie machen zumindest einen Wasserschloss.
Eine Flasche, wo die Drainage bei Wasser geschloss ist,
dass keine Luft zurückkommt, sondern nur Luftlauch reingeht.
Dann wird man Wasserschloss.
Wasserschloss.
Absorgung, Telenis?
Sorg, Sorg, Sorg, Sorg, ja, Sorg. Oder Sorg-Trinage, kann man auch sagen. Unter Sorg, dann kann man die
die Sorgstärke einstellen, kann man ja so messen, so und so viel Wassersäule, 10 Zentimeter, 12
Zentimeter Wassersäule gibt es so verschiedene Messstäbe, aber es ist Detail, wir wissen
jetzt gar nicht so. Okay, Sie haben Torx-Trinage gemacht und das hat der Patient auch immer viel
besser Luft bekommen. Was ist das Problem, wenn Sie keine Trinage legen, was kann passieren,
im schlimmsten Fall als Komplikation eines Pnomotorax? Vielleicht kann ich die anderen
in Nerven oder Arterielle? Was kann passieren bei Pnomotorax? Ist Pnomotorax sterben oder ist es
ein einfacher Problem? Warum legt man gleich Trinage? Was ist das Problem? Was ist so ein Worst
Case beim Pnomotorax? Was kann passieren? Habt ihr das gesehen? Ja, haben wir es schon mal gehört von
einem Spannungs-Pnomotorax, dass so das mit jedem Atemzug mehr und mehr Luft reinkommt,
ja, in diese Höhle, ja, dass die Luft mehr und mehr kollabiert und dann kann es mit
verschieben, ja. Wenn die Gefäß abdrücken, dann ist der Patient tot, dann ist er schock und
dann kann es durchgeführt werden. Das ist gefährlich, deswegen muss man bei Spannungs-Pnomotorax
ganz schnell reagieren und auch nicht warten bis da Blutgerätungsbälle da sind oder so was.
Wenn die Patienten sehen, dass sich die Patienten jede Minute verschlechtert,
dann müssen sie reagieren. Also das Hauptkomplikation ist Spannungs-Pnomotorax mit lethalem
Ausgang, ja, also die Patienten kann sterben daran, ja. Gut, was kann bei der Plowax-Trinage
passieren, wenn sie Plowax-Trinage anlegen? Was kann passieren als Komplikation?
Bei Anlegen, ja, vielleicht Verlöschungen, die Nerven oder Akteriellen im Kostalbereich, es könnte sein, ja.
Was passiert dann? Dann ist die Luft weg, aber dafür ist dann Blut drin in der, in der, in der
im Öhrer-Baum, ja, in der Blur, in der Blur, in der Blur, in der Blur. Ja, in der Blur, in der Blur.
Hematotorax, ja. Hematotorax, ja. Hematotorax. Auch kann passieren. Und was kann noch passieren
als Komplikation, was nicht so schlimm ist, aber auch manchmal störend ist? Also die Kollegen schreiben
schon hier, heftig, störend, glas, alles richtig. Ja. Ich glaube, auf alle spezielle Sachen hinaus,
die klinisch jetzt nicht so schlimm ist, aber manchmal den Patienten sehr stört.
Der Kniester dann, der Patient, Kniester, Kniester. Can you hear what? Kniestern? Nein.
Was ist Türkisch-Kniestern? Ja, weiß ich.
Ne, der Latvianer-Kniester, ne, ses çıkarma, cittir, cittir, cittir.
Kräptan.
Kräptan, aber kliessern, kniestern, hautemphysiöse, ja.
Ja, hautemphysiöse, ja.
Kräptation auch, by the way.
Unmannsagen Kräptation auf Türkisch, ja.
Nein, nicht Türkisch, Kräptation, not Danish.
Ja, türkisch, gibt es nicht, ne?
Kräptation, not Danish.
Türkisch, Jürgen haben keine Komplikation, ne?
Karla, Karla, Jürgen, ne, sesi, die, sagt Universum.
Ne, der, hautemphysiöse, ja, wie sie, hautemphysiöse, kann passieren, ja.
Genau, alles, alles nix gefährliches, aber muss halt dann gucken,
dass meine Trainage normal korrekt liegt, ja.
Ja, okay.
Gut.
Was kann man noch machen?
Sie haben jetzt die Torachs-Trainage gelegt,
lassen jetzt die Torachs-Trainage ein, zwei Tage liegen,
machen einen Kontrollbild natürlich, damit die Lunge sich wieder ausdehnt,
die Lunge ist ausgebähnt, dann klemmen Sie die Nage ab, oder nicht, wie auch immer,
und ziehen da die Trainage, und dann gibt die Lunge wieder Kollaps.
Was machen Sie dann?
Normaler Torachs-Trainage, richtig, ja.
Dann legen Sie nochmal Torachs-Trainage, also die Patienten, die spontan
Pnomotorachs bekommen, haben ein Risiko, wiederholt Pnomotorachs-C's zu bekommen, ja.
Woran liegt das? Was ist der Grund dafür?
Was ist bei dem Patienten vermutlich der Grund gewesen,
warum er Pnomotorachs bekommen hat?
Ja, das ist eine Rauchung.
Ja, aber Rauchen, was macht Rauchen? Rauchen Pnomotorachs? Nein.
Was macht Rauchen?
Denken Sie mal an die Anamnese, Familienanamnese vom Vater.
Das ist auch die Video unter M4Sem.
M4Sem, ja, das sind M4Sem-Plasen, die platzen einfach dann, ja.
Was kann man machen, wenn so etwas wiederholt kommt?
Den Patienten kann man dann nämlich lebenslang mit Torachs-Trainage lassen,
das geht ja nicht, ja. Was kann man dann machen?
Man kann so M4Sem-Bulle resetzieren, ja.
Wenn es sehr viele sind, dann kann man die operativ entfernen,
damit die Lunge dann oben wieder mit den normalen Lungengröße kleben bleibt, ja,
an dieser Stille, ja.
Nicht unbedingt Pleurodese, aber das ist, sagen Sie, direkt durch die
Operation Resektion ist das eh ein Reiz, der dann sozusagen eine Verklebung führt.
Man macht das jetzt nicht medikamentös unbedingt.
Okay, haben wir die wichtigsten Sachen gefragt?
Aber was sagen Sie dem Patienten, was er dann später machen soll,
wenn dann sein Torachs ist wieder normal, spontan?
Also, der Torachs ist weg, was soll er machen?
Nach der stationellen Behandlung, oder?
Genau.
Nikoling, Rheinz, ja.
Er will dann Urlaub fliegen, darf er fliegen?
Er schiebt nur wieder.
Er will jetzt wieder in zwei Wochen nach Dubai fliegen, darf er wieder fliegen?
Nein.
Ich bin nicht sicher, aber...
Also erst mal nicht, ja. Ich würde auch ein paar Wochen warten,
wenn ich da wieder fliegen kann.
Also das Risiko ist, dass dann beim Flugreisen wieder was passiert ist da
durch den Druckausgleich.
Wie viel lange?
Also weiß ich nicht, bei, muss ich sagen, kann ich nicht sagen.
Also ich würde, mittlerweile sind die Torachs-Chirurgen da sehr locker.
Also die machen sogar fast keine Angaben,
weil ich würde mindestens mal sechs Wochen warten.
Aber ich muss auch nachfragen,
ich habe keine Informationen über die Leitlinie, wie es empfohlen ist.
Was sollte da noch beachten der Patient?
Er ist leidenschaftlicher Taucher, also er macht Tauchen so.
Darf er Tauchen gehen?
Tauchen.
Tauchen, wissen Sie, was Tauchen ist?
Oder haben Sie Hobbys im Daugestück?
Na, Tauchen.
Darf er Tauchen?
Nein.
Darf er auch nicht tauchen, ja?
Nein, natürlich.
Erst mal nicht, für später weiß ich nicht genau,
aber erst mal keine Flugreisen, kein Tauchsport und Nikotinkarrenz.
Okay, haben wir das wichtig.
Ich gucke gerade beim Chat noch mal nach,
was es so als Probleme gab oder noch als Nachrichten.
Tension, Plumatars, Spannungstom, Plumatars auf Deutsch, Blutung, Infektion, Schock,
kann passiert, Schild, ein bisschen Repetition.
Okay, Reaktion, Claudese.
Dann haben wir alles, alles Wichtige, glaube ich, gefragt, gell?
Okay, gut.
Wie war die Alarmmese? War gut?
Ja, vielen Dank.
Ich habe viele Dinge gelernt.
Eine Sache haben wir vergessen zu besprechen,
das machen wir noch ganz kurz.
Der Patient hat gesagt, er hat eine Patientenverfügung,
er will nicht auf Inventivstationen gehen, gell?
Ja, erst mal habe ich nicht gedacht,
das ist spontan Pneumatorax.
Deswegen antwortete ich, ja.
Aber es ist ja gut.
Er will nicht an die Maschine, er will keinen Lebensverdägen Maßnahmen.
Aber wenn der jetzt Pneumatorax hat,
machen Sie die Drennage? Ja oder nein bei den Patienten.
Erst mal Drennage, ich glaube.
Ja, und will der Patient auch,
will ich da ein?
Gibt es ein Einverstandenes dafür?
Was meinen Sie? Nein, aber wir müssen eine Aufklärung erklären.
Worauf? Einwilligung einholen,
müssen wir eine Einwilligung einholen.
Ja, das müssen Sie auf jeden Fall.
Aber diese Patientenverfügung,
wofür sind die generell von Patienten gedacht?
Was ist die Absicht von Patienten, wenn sie sowas ausfüllen?
Dass, wenn sie ins Krankenhaus kommen, nichts operiert wird?
Oder was ist der Hintergedanke?
Warum machen Sie das?
Das ist vor allen Dingen bei Krankheiten oder Zuständen,
die irreversibel sind,
die keine Chance auf Besserung haben, also Heilung oder Verbesserung,
weil sie nicht leiden wollen, dann wollen sie nicht Maschine haben.
Bei so einem Fall, wo einfach nur eine Drennage gelegt wird,
der Patient wieder völlig normal ist,
ist das eine ganz andere Situation.
Das hat mit Patientenaufklärung nichts zu tun, aber sie haben Recht.
Trotzdem muss man den Patienten aufgehen, sagen, passen auf.
Das ist keine lebensverlängende Maßnahme in dem Sinne,
sondern das ist eine Krankheit, die mal schnell beheben kann,
so wie die Milz-Ruptur auch.
Kann man auch beheben, dann lebt der Patient ganz normal.
Also diese Patientenverfügung gilt meistens für schwere,
chronische Krankheiten, die keine Aussicht auf Verbesserung haben.
Insofern solche Kleinigkeiten, wie zum Beispiel,
wenn man so ein Clomotorax, so ein Torax-Trenage hat,
ist damit meistens nicht gemein von Patienten.
Das muss man dann mal erklären.
Wir müssen nicht einholen.
Doch, du musst immer einholen.
Aber ich ...
Noch ein paar Jahre.
Ja, schön, wenn es nur ein Notfall ist, zum Beispiel,
der Patient hat zum Beispiel Lungenkrebs.
Ja, okay, okay.
Ein Notfall zum Beispiel Herzinfarkt,
dann will er nicht reanimiert werden.
Das ist das anderes.
Wenn ein Patient jetzt spontan, völlig gesund ist
und ein Clomotorax bekommt, ist eine ganz andere Situation.
Man muss es auch einholen.
Aber diese Patientenverfügung ist für sie dann nicht so wichtig,
wie bei diesem chronisch kranken Patienten.
Und sie müssen wissen, was der damit meint.
Der meint das ja für andere Situationen,
nicht für diese Situation.
Deswegen.
Nicht, dass man den Fehler macht,
und das ist eine ganz andere Situation.
Wir machen gar nichts mehr.
Das sollte man nicht machen.
Ja.
Und auch in so einem Fall,
wenn zum Beispiel jetzt hatte jemand geschrieben,
Versicht auf Wiederbelebungsmaßnahmen,
würde ich nicht machen.
Es geht meistens in der Patientverfügung darum,
dass man sozusagen, wenn man eine Wiederbelebung macht,
dass man dann Patienten noch ein Chroma hat, zum Beispiel.
Das Risiko ist immer da, muss man sagen.
Wenn man in der Praxis steht oder sitzt im Ambulanz,
man hat spontan auf einmal einen Herzstil stand,
mit wegen vom Motorax, dann würde ich den reinimieren.
Auch wenn in Patientverfügung steht,
ich möchte keine Wiederbelebung haben.
Das ist ein Grenzbereich,
aber in so einem Fall muss man dann für den Patienten entscheiden.
Für Christpatienten ist auch nicht mehr gültig.
Man muss immer das für den Einzelfall sehen.
Und wenn man die Chance hat,
muss man es mit dem Patienten besprechen.
Manche Patienten sagen, sie wollen kann,
sie wollen die Ernährung haben, beispielsweise.
Weil sie denken, sie müssen dann länger leiden.
Manchmal gibt es Situationen,
wo auch Christpatienten mal Infusionen- Ernährung bekommen können,
kurzfristig, und dass es leidend verlängend wird.
Das kann man besprechen.
Also Patientverfügung ist nur eine Grundlage für sie,
eine Entscheidung zu treffen.
Aber immer wissen, was eigentlich der Patient gemeint haben könnte damit.
Diese Patienten,
wir haben welche,
welche Einteilung gemacht
für Triage.
Wir haben gar keine Einteilung gemacht bei ihm.
Ja, erste Mal,
der Patient hat
im Notfall und eine Geschütte.
Im Notfall mit dieser Patient,
wenn ich den habe,
wird er ganz normal behandelt wie alle anderen Patienten auch.
Ja, rot, rot.
Ich kenne sich einzeln auch nicht rot und grün, weiß ich nicht.
Ja, und deswegen,
wir müssen erstmal eine Einbildung,
alle Eingriffe einholen.
Betrugstrinage müssen einen einigen holen, ja, ist richtig.
Aber wenn er, sag ich mal,
jetzt gerade im Gespräch umkippt, ja,
können sie keinen Einbildungen holen,
müssen reagieren, dann ist Notfall.
Ja.